[Music]
okay so I raise the game designer I was
not able to talk him out of this and
he's actually pretty damn good at it
which kind of really worries me because
well he should get a real job but the
upshot of that is this a couple years
back
CD Projekt approached my business
manager and said we like to do a
tabletop version of the widget and we're
already working so far yeah I'd gone
over like twice by a point maybe three
times they'd met her because they we had
a tremendous amount of contracts that we
had to work out and they said you know
you know somebody we could you know get
to do this and she said well I know go
talk Mike and I said I don't do fantasy
I mean I love Witcher I've enjoyed
playing it but I'm not really the best
fantasy guy I'm a science-fiction guy so
I don't know and my son who at that
point was 18 or 19 said I want to do it
and I said okay here's the deal if you
want to do it I'm not helping you I'm
not writing it for you you have to pitch
it run it drive it and make it happen
and he said okay I'm on you're on
so literally the next time we went out
Lisa was there for business stuff was we
working on something complex I remember
what it was that when she had business I
was doing stuff with the cyberpunk
team Cody comes along oftentimes because
his input on a cyberpunk team is very
solid and pretty well respected in the
team and he went and pitched it at the
head of marketing who originally
suggested that we looked for someone so
he'd have to see this picture I'm going
in and out between meetings and he's in
an office and he's talking to they had a
market
and he's nodding the head of marketing
and they're having a good time I'm going
okay they haven't thrown out yet so I
come back about an hour later and he's
with somebody further up like one of the
producers and the producers going yeah
that would be really good I see how you
solve that problem you know and they're
going at it I'm going okay that's
president and I come back an hour later
and he's with the president of company
and they're going yeah well we could do
this and these things and all that and
I'm going whoa okay and by the end of
the day we had the license hammered out
and so he had pitched it and I'm going
okay you talked yourself into this can
you back it and it turned out that when
he went to talk to them he'd already
done most of the design work already and
he knew and knows The Witcher to an
insane level of detail and he also
drafted my wife who was all the business
manager into writing with it as well
most people don't know it but my wife is
actually a really good writer who never
admits it she wrote several of the best
gangs in cyberpunk and a lot of
background material and she's done
everything from projects and DND
products and so forth like that never
admits it and he said well you like
which as much as I do so what can you do
so he ended up being her boss as well as
other people on the team of the editors
and so forth and he built a Witcher team
and they went through every book they
went through every game that it existed
they went through every comic the old TV
show I mean it's just sewing through
everything it was Witcher Central they
yeah I know and they and the hexer and
then they even went you know it was so
far as they signed up to go to Witcher
camp last year and it was a snafu where
they couldn't get under their plane
flights in time but yeah they were gonna
go off and be running around through the
you know wilds of Poland with swords on
their backs in which our camp
and what they turned out was just a damn
fine piece of work and I did not get
involved into it until they finally said
okay we have enough of it to sue their
matches your ear specs and I did that
and I took the other designers and had
them beat up on it and I said yeah this
is really solid and CD PR also went
through it and had us have outside
people look at it and that's one reason
it took a long time was we had to make
sure everything was there you know that
things worked and that it felt right but
when you're doing with people who are
willing to learn polish so they can read
the books so they can know what was
happening in the original these are
people who really really care about what
they've created and it shows
you